and Hip-Hop is like yo he's gay as [__]
dog like like [__] that dude sure you
could wake up and just paint every day
but like you got to pay your bills a lot
of hip-hop is like really it just it's
like real terrible like the the consumer
I do my best to treat everybody with the
same respect I treat you like I would
treat my garbage man can rapper singer
songwriter and record producer his debut
studio album under pressure was released
in October of 2014 to critical success
Under Pressure debuted at number four on
the U.S billboard 200 chart he's logic
and here's my take on his top 10 rules
for Success rule number six is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the to the end for some
special bonus clips
and Hip Hop is like yo he's gay as [__]
that dude like you know what I mean like
I just why don't you like them you know
what he can rap he got a good story his
flows are cool for sure I just don't
like them though like and it's like so
ignorant it's crazy so like yeah years
ago you know what I'm saying when I
first got on blogs and I'd be excited
I'd read comments but now it's just like
there's no point to read comments yeah
it's either two it's either too positive
which can lead you to like beheaded
where it's too negative which could make
you try to create music to get them to
stop hating on you it's like somebody
being like yeah he should rap like this
he should rap like that I don't like the
way he raps and then the person changes
up how they rap to try to you know make
that person like them and then they're
like man he ain't even being himself
like after you change so it's like you
can't win man right you can't win no
matter what you do right for sure so for
me I don't listen to the hate I don't
listen to love too much I just you know
take it all in stride like I love what I
do and as long as I can wake up every
day and feel that thing just for the
money because if you do it just for the
money
um you won't you'll never be happy do
what you love because if you do what you
love and you wake up every day doing
that it doesn't matter because you'll be
happy
which I think is I I think it's 100 True
to an extent
you know like you sure you could wake up
and just pain every day but like you got
to pay your bills do you know what I
mean like there's a there's a way you
got to do it so
um sure waking up and painting every day
but if painting isn't paying your bills
so it's just like yo make a way for
painting to pay your bills you see what
I'm saying maybe you paint for ad
companies or this or that on the side so
then you can pay whatever the hell you
want during that you know what I mean so
just whatever it is do what you love
um
and that's the biggest thing I've I've
that's that's my whole thing do what you
love it like you are a very friendly
person who's from a relatively tough
circumstance uh what made you that way
uh I think I like I truly believe that
you're a product of your environment you
know what I'm saying so we had it really
bad and you know my sister's got
pregnant and my my brothers were selling
drugs and these are and doing drugs and
these are the things that they saw and
they went that route you know I actually
have a song on the album where I took
because I've talked about my dog's my
dad's drug abuse for many years now and
I really delve into it on the album and
one of the things that I you know he
called me and was like you know I really
wish he would stop talking about that
and I was like well I wish you had been
a father and been there and I would wish
that you would understand that by me
writing this is ten times better than me
using those same and drugs drugs and
inflicting them upon myself to get over
it so maybe you should like not be so
selfish and realize it right and be
happy that my way of dealing with it's
positive exactly so but what I what I'm
saying as far as you know being a
product of your environment is where
they may have chosen a you know the
wrong path per se you know I I saw it
and it made me kind of go in the right
direction I guess that's just up to God
not to sound like cliche again but
that's what that is but it's also up to
you I mean you you were a kid who made
that decision you're like I'm not gonna
do that but I just believe in honor and
Valor man like we live you know this
demographic like no I'm not talking
about the purest I'm not talking about
people like yourself but like a lot of
hip-hop is like really it just it's like
real terrible like the the consumer
because all they care about is like it's
like it's almost I'd be more you know
legitimately acceptable if I was you
know six two black with dreads and total
guns and then people would be like oh
he's a real rapper as opposed to like
carrying myself with Grace and speaking
how I speak and not trying to throw the
accent on everything and like you know
I'm just me man and I think if anything
that's going to be more authentic in the
long run
um rather than trying to pretend to be
someone I'm not I've gone through those
same experiences you know I was taught
in cooked crack in my kitchen at from 12
to you know like in my teenage years to
learn and see what these things were
about and understand because they we're
going on in my household but I don't
glorify it I'm not like yeah we cooking
crack we've got this I'm like damn why
was I 12 years old and my my sister's
baby daddy would show me how to cook
crack like where were my parents you
know what I mean and explaining that
status all the negative experiences that
I might have gone through or whatever
the case may be built uh a much more
positive person you know what I mean
because that's why I'm so positive all
the time I like to tell people like you
know I'll go on Twitter and I'll say you
know my whole motto which is peace love
and positivity follow your dreams do
what you love in life whatever that
might be and um you know I've been
saying it for years and it started with
me telling myself because nobody else
was telling me nobody was telling me to
follow my dreams or that I could do it
or that I could be somebody and then it
ended up me telling myself this in songs
I ended up telling millions of people
that listen to it which is it which is
really crazy
um and and just always doing my best to
be a good person because when I first
started like imagine imagine going
somewhere and meeting somebody in the
industry and they're like walk past you
and don't even look you in the face or
talk to you or say hello and then then
you start to get a buzz but people still
aren't sure who you are and then it's
like oh this is logic he's got so and so
such amount of views on YouTube and
they're like oh what's up but it's like
he's like nah you know so so me I I do
my best to treat everybody with the same
respect I treat you like I would treat
my garbage man or the president it's
just the same it doesn't anybody do you
feel underrated as a rapper not as of
lately like which is crazy for a long
time man for years I was pissed so a
song on the album called buried alive is
about that exact thing you know it's
about like me kind of going how come he
gets the so-and-so co-signer how come he
gets that or how come they get that I
can tour the world I can sell out shows
I got fans I got this what the [__] man
like being angry you know I had a friend
tell me she basically said those same
people who have the cosines and have
this and have the looks are the same
people are going how come I ain't got
fans like this then how come I can't
Tour on my own how come I can't get this
like what the [__] so I kind of put
things in perspective for me and let me
go okay I don't have it yet but if I
keep fighting and I keep working hard
and I keep staying on this path it's
gonna happen you know and as of late
within the last few months man just from
you know like releasing the singles and
the music videos in life this solid body
of work I've truly began to to 16 years
old before they did the English dub of
Akira I saw it when I was a kid I didn't
know what it was it was terrifying
disturbing and very beautiful all at the
same time and then so when kind of
digging into this album I was like man
that's that's where I kind of really
want to take it I want to just be fully
creative you know
and it's like man you know what like who
cares what's this what's that or if I
got to fit in with this person or that
person then I realize like all my fans
most of them [__] don't fit in
with nobody and that's and then they fit
in with everybody else on my planet you
know what I mean like all the fans so
many people like like I watch these fan
submissions because you know I'm doing
this tour fan tour
and they're like
your music is amazing but honestly dude
it's your message and the people I've
met because of your music and it's like
whoa that's crazy
that's what matters the most you know my
whole mentality has been just like I
don't give a sh like I don't give a damn
about nothing man I used to care so much
like what people thought because I love
this culture so I really love this
culture but this culture is also really
[__] up so I was like you know what
[__] it like I'm I'm just gonna be me
I'm gonna do me so when I when I told
myself I'm gonna create an album about
anime in space and I was like I'm gonna
do it but I'm gonna do it in a way where
if you don't give a damn about this you
can just
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because life asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I also love to know what
your logic's top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you and why which is
the clips resonated most with you leave
it in the comments below and I will join
in the discussion finally I want to give
a quick shout out to Catherine pear
Catherine thank you so much for picking
up a cop in my book if you guys watching
if you want to change that shout out in
a future video make sure to get the book
and email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon
but this is what I want you to do mix up
that Rubik's Cube oh extremely bad go
ahead
mix it up extremely bad now what I want
you to do is I'm going to put on an
instrumental okay and you got a
freestyle freestyle in your mind yeah
okay so I might say some crazy I don't
know what I'm gonna be saying but you
got a freestyle while you're doing that
Rubik's Cube she is really trying yeah
take it and throw it against the wall
it could either be freestyle or you
could just give me something from the
album but I want your concentration to
be on lyrics as well okay as what's
going on with this room half the head
rub the tummy kind of stuff all righty
you all right she's handing it to Luigi
now Louie is mixing it up best believe
that yeah all righty all right pretty
good that looks pretty much right
there's no two colors
this is like really awesome let me see
it toss it over here real quick
I'm looking at all these Blues here oh
this is well oil too this is well broken
in yeah
you know what I'm saying have you ever
seen in a competition no my wife wants
to put me in I think you should and I
talked to Juicy J and Juicy J was like
I'll come and I'll and I'll support you
he's like yeah he's like as long as I
can get drunk I'll be there
all right
logic here we go all righty and we you
know what I don't even you could time
them but I'm not really going for time
okay I'm I'm going for logic
all right now you gotta you gotta make
sure that you kicking lyrics while
you're doing this logic check this is
what we do no no give me the next one
give me the next one hold up what about
this one yeah oh check check oh yeah see
I like this BPM here we go you ready
uh-huh here we go check it I'm about to
spit the vibe this is how we do it
whether it's that new of that try we
always gotta keep it alive you know my
vision and tell it crazy the flow is
never lazy see I don't even know what
I'm saying I'm just vacating in Barbados
the second I get it is crazy cause she
Jamaican me crazy I don't know I'm just
spitting this rhyme I gotta spit it on
time the second I do it it's strictly
come out my mind they say they know the
deal I always keep it real and yes I get
it like that this is how we do I got my
first hat that happy wife happy life not
a flow it's never trife I gotta get it
like this it's hella crazy NADA the flow
is never lazy and it doesn't even make
sense it doesn't even matter I'm just
spitting at that random thought it can't
be taught This Is How We Do It speaking
of thoughts I can't fade These Hoes
where y'all been where y'all going this
is how we do it I don't even know what
I'm saying I ain't knowing I'm just
keeping this I got this Rubik's Cube
It's got the lube and pause on that we
all on that and this is how we do it
when I spit these Rhymes it's it's kind
of crazy oh no and y'all mess this
Rubik's Cube up hold up hold up y'all
messed it up so I gotta flip this around
take it out put it back in now I do the
algorithm real slick real smooth This Is
How We Do It Like a criminal flow so
medicinal my stuff is heavily medicated
never eradicated they evacuated the
second I arrived on the scene I spit it
hella clean spit it hella mean thought I
had it for a second but I didn't gotta
bring it back this is like it's really
crazy when you spit it like this oh my
God y'all really mess this thing up go
ahead now I messed it up y'all messed it
up I gotta bring it back y'all was
flipping it too hard with your fingers
I'm linging I'm lingering I got it I'm
singing I'm bringing them in and this is
how we do it let me begin I would have
sold it faster if y'all ain't messing up
but it's all good we gotta keep it going
shout out to corrupt that West coaster
the holy The One and Only The Grail spit
a second I get it and I prevail
[Applause]
get there
two freestyle never done